the topic that i decided to write about
was with regard to uh something that you
hear
islamophobes often bring up you know
whether it be in facebook comments or on
youtube
it's usually the number one thing you
see whenever somebody wants to criticize
islam
and it's
the prophet muhammad saw islam's
marriage to aisha mother of believers so
i'm sure you all understand what i'm
talking about i'm sure you've seen a lot
of the vulgarity addressed towards our
prophet and the mother of believers um
in these comments and i'm sure it's all
made you very
very uncomfortable and um
likewise it's made me very uncomfortable
it's made me
very emotional and that was one of my
primary motivations for actually writing
about this topic not only do muslims
part of our faith is that we should
respect and love the prophet but also
his family members and whenever you hear
something bad about your family member
you know you can't help but feel
vulnerable and feel upset and feel you
know just just feel like your world has
been shattered in some way
and you want to respond to those
allegations you want to protect your
family members those that you love and
um
our responses
are primarily driven by that love and by
that sensitivity and by that
that
by the insults that that completely
undermine the respect and dignity of
those we care about
so i would say that was my primary
motivation for addressing this topic the
other motivation though is more
practical in the sense that this is
probably the number one criticism that
you hear against islam in the
contemporary period and i feel like it
hasn't been adequately addressed now
personally when i when i first
uh saw this criticism because i'm a
convert to islam so i mean this is one
one of the things that i actually saw
one of the first things i saw when i
came to islam
from its critics was regarding this
issue and it actually didn't
bother me in the sense of you know
academically speaking it didn't bother
me in the sense of like
putting any doubts in my mind to be
honest with you because um i had read a
lot of history and a lot of
scientific journals on anthropology and
you know i had studied morality to a
great extent you know during my
philosophy
grad education so for me it wasn't
difficult to understand why people
married early uh you know in the past uh
you know primarily due to the fact that
you know um mortality rates were much
higher uh people had much more simple
lives you know
death was an ever-present reality and
people had to prepare for that so
in the past marrying early was quite
normal because you know when you live in
a society where
life is so unexpected and death is so
unexpected um you have to prepare as
early as possible in today's world we
have so many options in today's world we
have so many conveniences
where childhood can be extended for as
long as we want even until our 20s
where we don't have to worry so much
but back then that wasn't the case
back then they had to prepare for life
much earlier
so that future generations could have
this life
because in all honesty we wouldn't even
be here today had our ancestors not made
those sacrifices had not made those
those decisions that they did morality
doesn't change
it's always wrong to murder it's always
wrong to steal and it's always wrong to
abuse and to take advantage of children
but what does change
are the conditions of humanity
and i think we have such a limited
understanding of morality today that we
don't comprehend the difficulties of the
past and why certain things were
actually moral
and that's what my paper attempts to
address in the most comprehensive way
possible
and my paper is not the only one there's
actually a collection of papers on this
particular issue
and i think that joaquin institute has
gone to great lengths to provide not
only the most comprehensive answer but
the definitive answer
to this issue
and i hope that
despite being such a
sensitive topic despite being such a
controversial issue
that inshallah you benefit from this and
that not only strengthens your yakin but
future generations to come
on
you